hello and welcome to my video series of
more bio explained in three minutes
where i explain the concept in more bio
in just three minutes so if you haven't
yet subscribed hit that subscribe button
today's installment will talk about hot
start pcr
so hot start pcr is just like any other
pcr
there would be a denaturation step
primary annealing step and there would
be amplification
but the name has the inner meaning hot
start
so that has to deal with temperature
and there should be a temperature
dependent control in this particular pcr
reaction
so in the hot start pcr the tac
polymerase can only
function at higher temperature or starts
showing its function
at higher temperature and this minimizes
non-specific amplification
at lower temperature so in this video we
would understand the overall concept
behind that
so stay tuned till the end hotspot pcr
mix contains
as usual the template dna forward
reverse primer dntp
polymerase mgcl2 containing buffer
all of these but along with it it has a
chemical x and we need to understand
what this chemical x
is so in pcr reaction
our biggest problem is sometimes we get
non-specific bands as shown here
so we don't want these non-specific
bands but we need ways to overcome it
and one of the ways to do a hot start
pcr
in normal pcr makes when we add
a forward reverse primer tag polymerase
dntp in the master mix
some reaction already starts in that
situation
so these primers if they are not
designed optimally then they can
anneal with one another and the
polymerase can sit on this primer and
start
amplifying or start its action so this
leads to primer dimer formation
and as a result what happens is when we
have
the real scenario that means the
template is added in that situation
we don't have enough amount of timer
left for the amplification
that means our amplification efficiency
is decreased and
most likely we are going to get some
kind of a
thinner band or low intensity band in
the special reaction
in order to overcome this kind of
problems
we need to reduce the activity of
tack pole in lower temperatures
and how it is done very simple there
could be monoclonal antibodies which are
heat labile
afry bodies small molecules or aptamers
which can interact with the that
polymerase in
lower temperature and can inhibit
the tag polymerase activity under lower
temperature
that means even if the tag polymerase
would be present
and sitting there it would not start its
amplifi
its polymerization activity then and
there
now this stack polymerase can only show
its action
when the temperature is elevated when
the temperature rises to
95 degree centigrade all of these
inhibitory effects
can get can can get abolished
as a result this stack polymerase is
active
and it can perform its job in terms of
amplification
and that ensures non-specific
amplification
is reduced so as per summary we have
learned that tag polymerase can function
at higher temperature
but remains inactive in lower
temperature especially in case of hot
start pcr
and hot start pcr prevents undesired
products
and increase the amplification
efficiency so if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up you can join
my patreon and you can also
help me by your donation if you are
indian visitor you can
use this qr code to support my channel
and as usual
like share and subscribe you can also
take my academic course thank you